all right i have something amazing for
you guys
within just a couple of weeks of the
leaked news
that the supreme court will soon be
overturning roe v wade
2022
house of representatives polling has
completely reversed and in a new npr pbs
marist national poll democrats are now
plus 5 over republicans looking at the
november congressional elections now
we're not going to go crazy and get
ahead of ourselves i'm not going to
start ripping apart my microphone and
burning it and celebrating anything not
that i would do that anyway we're going
to look through this piece by piece and
in order to do that we have to first
start with what would we expect
in such a midterm
typically
in a midterm
the party that is not in the white house
does well
right now
democrats are in the white house joe
biden took the white house from trump in
2020 and so we would expect republicans
to do really well in the midterms now
let's look at some previous examples in
2018 after donald trump took power in
2016 democrats were plus seven in
polling going into the midterms and they
ended up plus eight in an aggregate of
congressional races okay trump wins
next midterm democrats plus seven eight
in the 2014 midterms after barack obama
won re-election republicans were plus
two and they ended up winning by almost
plus six
obama re-election republicans win okay
2010 barack obama had just won in 2008
over john mccain taking the white house
from republicans previously held by
george w bush obama wins 2008
2010 republicans were plus nine in the
midterms ended up plus seven in those
midterms disastrous midterms for
democrats okay so
normally these first midterms uh in
particular the first ones but even after
a democratic reelection you expect to
see republicans do well we now have a a
stunning new poll
these numbers you really have to see
them to believe them
47
of registered voters
now say they will support the democrat
on the ballot in this year's
congressional midterm while 42 say they
will back the republican that is plus
five for democrats
in advance of these midterms
now we want to be thorough
we don't look at just one poll we look
at an average of recent polls and if you
look at the real clear politics average
of recent polls
you still have republicans plus two
looking at the generic congressional
vote now that is dramatically lower than
it has been
in any recent first midterm after the
party controlling the white house
changes power and it is declining
whereas republicans were polling about
an average of 48 percent in february
and about 47
in mid-march and they peaked at uh 47
again in mid-may now republicans are
down from where they were
could republicans still will win of
course of course it's still the most
likely scenario this is just one poll
but we are now seeing multiple polls in
an economist yougov poll democrats are
leading congressional vote generic in a
political morning consult poll democrats
are leading and yes in that recent npr
pbs marist poll i just mentioned
democrats are now plus five what this
means
is that the midterm might not be over
the impact of the roe v wade news
especially if and when it becomes
official when the supreme court finally
announces its ruling
it could really give democrats a boost
and what it means at the individual
level is every one of us must vote
if you've ever voted before you should
vote
if you've ever thought about voting you
should vote if you've never voted you
should vote if you weren't old enough to
vote in 2020 but now you're old enough
to vote legally of course you should
vote if you've ever heard of voting like
if that's a concept you've ever heard
about you should vote because it doesn't
have to be the disaster that it was
shaping up to be
it seems as though the forthcoming roe v
wade decision
is absolutely uh hurting republicans one
other interesting note from that poll
which i think just should be mentioned
is on the question of overturning roe v
wade 64
of americans do not believe roe v wade
should be overturned basically by a two
to one margin two-thirds one-third
americans do not want the supreme court
to overturn roe v wade so if and when
that happens
it could be exactly the boost on which
democrats might be able to ride to okay
could it be victory in november maybe
but could it be a much much smaller loss
than what it was looking like three
months ago
that very much could be and as i've said
before
joe biden hasn't done that much to help
democrats in november
uh and we'll take all the help we can
get to get these republicans or keep
these wacky republicans out of power
if they want to hurt themselves by
virtue of their own supreme court picks
making a very unpopular decision when it
comes to roe v wade i'll take the help
from anybody we can get it uh anybody we
can get it from i guess i should say let
me know your thoughts let me know what
you make of this new polling and
remember that we are now just one week
away monday memorial day we will be
doing a one day membership special all
you need to do to be notified is get on
my mailing list at davidpakman.com and
then on memorial day you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to avail
yourself
of this extraordinary membership
discount if you want to join today you
can do so at joinpakman.com we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
there's been a ton of fear-mongering
lately by traditional corporate media
about the economic and financial
landscape and if you're looking for
financial news that's more calm and
collected without the hype without the
click bait check out our sponsor the
daily upside it's a free business and
investing newsletter it goes out to 350
000 people including myself and it was
founded by a team of financial
professionals with the whole goal of
just providing clarity and context for
the events that are happening in the
world of business economics and finance
every weekday they deliver a morning
brief followed by more detailed stories
about what's shaping the economics and
business world i read the daily upside
all the time
because it's informative it's witty and
it's not dumbed down i just read a great
article about the real impact of the
russian sanctions in russia
and if you're looking for a daily jump
start on the news that's affecting
economics and the markets the daily
upside is the perfect solution it's
totally free to sign up using the link
below